I brought you here for more than just a  view oh yeah I have to say the last five  years have been a nightmare come true  for me will you be my ex-wife the more I  think about my future the more I don't  want you in it will you give me my ring  back no your kids are gonna love having  two Christmases oh my god  now you can travel whenever you want  you're gonna be so happy sleeping with  other people honey  well daddy's little girl and finally  spend all night alone watching reality  TV again dad my friends and niece had a  divorce she recently had oral sex with  Jason Derulo we've had some good times  some bad time let's just call it even  okay I still get half your money though  right  yeah  you must be so tired of riding the same  dick for the last five years